aunque hoy no habrá eventos públicos
para conmemorar esta fecha los
seguidores de la princesa diana de gales
siguen acercándose a las afueras del
palacio de kensington en la que fuera su
residencia aquí en londres para dejar
cartas flores y rendir un homenaje a la
que es sin duda una de las grandes y
royals más queridas en toda la historia
y que se convirtió en un icono no solo
de la moda de belleza sino por su
trabajo en favor de las organizaciones
de caridad sus hijos harry y william
conmemorarán esta fecha de manera
privada en familia y por separado ya que
harvey viven los eeuu y william aquí en
inglaterra se sabe por la prensa que los
dos príncipes han decidido no seguir
conmemorando esta fecha de manera
pública la última vez que lo hicieron
fue hace cinco años para el aniversario
20 de la muerte de la princesa diana
cuando se presentó una estatua que
honraba justamente eso su vida y también
su trabajo por diferentes organizaciones
de caridad que hoy decora el palacio de
kensington pero esta fecha también se
recuerda como un punto de quiebre para
la monarquía que puso a tambalear está
por unos días tanto que la reina isabel
tuvo que ceder personalmente y permitir
un funeral de estado para la princesa
diana- pese a que no era parte ya de la
familia real oficialmente y a éste
asistieron al menos dos millones de
personas y millones más presenciaron
este funeral por televisión